Jasmin's in Detroit Michigan hi jasmine
and welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi
Dave thank you so much for taking my
call sure okay well my question is
should my husband and i consider
bankruptcy we're inspecting our second
April and I have been at home I've been
a stay-at-home mom with my daughter
who's now well she's one years old now
and I was taken off of work because of
the disability that came with my second
pregnancy so she's she's been the
primary one that spent works and I've
been home with her until teaching older
I I'm 20
you're what I'm 28 oh yeah okay and what
does he do for a living Staffing okay
and what does he make a year
he makes it's about 56,000 okay and how
much debt do you have we're about a
hundred hang out like 112 thousand I'm
trying to break that down for me how
much of that just student loans ninety
six thousand 334 and then I have credit
cards 2500 and his cans and collection
accounts that's about 36 and some change
and then also with my lifetime stately
share care car and our past least we
went over a mile - you also have an
overage of 2004 Ford on an old car that
you don't have anymore
well they so we returned our leash and
they put this in the newly
and we had an outstanding overage for
the mileage of 2000 that that we have to
pay that we're trying to work through
now with this new lease that we have how
long okay so how much is your lease
payment it's about two hundred and
eighty four dollars and we're expected
to old and what is the top a second what
is the how much time is left on that
leaves we have 17 months 17 months left
okay yeah all right now here's the thing
if you file bankruptcy you will still
owe the student loans and if you don't
turn in the car in the bankruptcy you
will still owe the lease payment so you
really would only be filing bankruptcy
on about $13,000 so it doesn't really do
much for you but I understand you've got
a baby and you've got a baby on the way
any minute and you're scared I get that
and that you have a right to be scared
but that's just that would be normal in
this situation so what we've got to do
instead is figure out what we're going
to do first and what we're gonna do
second okay the first thing you're going
to do the first thing you're going to do
is you're going to pay your rent or
house payment your food bill and your
lights and water and you're going to put
gas in the car the next thing you're
going to pay is the car payment until we
can get out of this car and don't you
ever lease a car again you go get a
thousand dollar beater car when you get
this one turned in and maybe 17 months
for you get out of it but at the end of
that time you turn it in and you get you
a beater car don't let them put you in
another lease you're getting killed with
these leases tell the student loan
people to jump in the creek because you
got no money it's called a hardship
deferral we're in the middle of a
hardship we can not pay ninety six
thousand dollars with two babies
brand-new babies and a fifty thousand
dollar income so when I will do that
right now so for now they're going to
get nothing but they're not going to get
any in bankruptcy and you've got to pay
them after bankrupt
anyway so the credit cards you can quit
paying them if you have to but if you do
your budget you buy food first lights
and water second shelter third
transportation fourth we call that the
four walls of your house the basic
necessities to live paying a student
loan paying a credit card paying a
collections or paying on the $2,000
overage on your last lease are not
necessities those are good things but
they're not to pay we want to pay them
and get them out of your life but
they're not necessities so they're far
down the list keep the list in order
here's what happens you'll be less
fearful if your belly is full your
lights and water are on and you're not
going to be evicted if you do those
things if you got lights and water heat
cool food and a place to live and you
know that that's done and you make
enough to do that and enough for that
matter pay this car payment although
it's bad deal but pay the car payment
you make enough to do all of those
things so you got something to drive a
place to live and you got food the rest
of this is a bunch of barking dogs out
in the backyard and we'll get around to
feeding them but right now they're just
going to Yap but they're in the backyard
they're not going to destroy your life
and then you begin to whittle at those
as you're able to get an income coming
in and as he's able to get his income up
with part-time jobs and career changes
and other things over time you begin to
beat you get rid of this car you begin
to beat your way through this and I'm
gonna help you I've been right where you
are when I was 28 years old I was just
as scared and lost as you are right now
and we're gonna put you into Financial
Peace University it's our nine week
class with a 1 year online membership as
well to every dollar and all the classes
audio video everything all the community
everything's online
and we're gonna put you in the nine week
class hold on Kelly's gonna pick up I'm
gonna pay for it you're gonna be okay
but you're going to follow what I teach
you to do
[Music]